ladies and gentlemen welcome to
GameSpot's III coverage here on day one
on the games must stage 1 of 2 Live
stages we have blazing all day today
from noon to six I'm your host Chris
waters so excited to be joining you for
this year's e3 it's already been a big
one so far we saw a ton of games at the
press conferences yesterday and then at
Nintendo Direct this morning but our
first demo is one you haven't seen and
one you really haven't seen anything
like joining me on stage Terry velman
the creator of heavy bullet as well as
Nigel from devolver digital Terry Nigel
welcome to the stage thank you very
happy to be here we're very excited to
be here showing off the game yeah we're
so psyched to kick off our show with you
guys I I wanted people to see gameplay
like almost immediately of this because
it's heavy bullets is such a visually
striking game I you know there's some
stuff that's going to be immediately
understandable to some folks there's a
gun in your hand they're their
environments that you're navigating
through but I feel like we're going to
need a little help understanding what
this game is all about so you start the
game with a gun six bullets and three
bones and you got to make your way
through eight levels to get to the
eighth one where the mainframe is like
glitching I gotta fix it so because the
world had security system that took care
of these monsters but now they're
attacking you instead of the monster so
I gotta deal with both of them at the
same time so you started the level the
levels are randomized so every time you
play it's a little bit different you
know or we know what's around the corner
and um you just got to be fast you got
to be precise and it's pretty hard and
you know their items they're a bunch of
stuff when you shoot a bullet like you
just killed the amp and there it is
bouncing around yeah and because you're
you know you don't have a lot of Clips
you don't have a lot of fast loaders
they're ready for you to just like
regatta or play with one bullet at a
time when you start the game you can
upgrade that so you can be a little more
bullets okay every time you kill
something you get these coins they're
jumping around right aha and I'm you can
use that to buy no items health and
upgrade your character you can also
deposit your money on the bank so if you
die you can withdraw on another run
fiscal responsibility ya gotta manage
your money yeah life insurance cuz if
you die sure
yeah you can get over being hello
responsible with your life decisions in
the same and then I got some of your
money back you can actually a less will
if you carry it with you and you die you
get all your money your bullets or bombs
everything back for a second run so you
can try again which if anyone has ever
played a roguelike before you know
that's a huge advantage because
otherwise you're wiping the slate clean
yeah yeah all right so this is we're
still here on the first of eight levels
you said yeah yeah and now we've sort of
been going through some doors what what
is traversing through the level like I
mean there's obviously sort of you know
taking care of these choppers coming at
you real hard and fast I like by the way
how they dissolve into the polygons into
their component parts it's cool I you
know is it's just sort of like vanquish
enemies and make smart financial
decisions or their puzzles or anything
you got to work out um you gotta figure
out how to kill the enemies the first
time you meet one like there's a bunch
of new enemies as you progress through
the game yeah you got to figure that out
and you can get pretty intense if you're
far into the game and you know you might
die and you see something new you got to
figure out how to kill that so there's
that most of the enemies die with just
one shot okay so that's kind of a
helpful because you only get six bullets
in sure but if there's four enemies here
and then four more around the corner
yeah you're in trouble because you only
have the six bullets that's when the
strategy kicks in you got a position
yourself you can add grow some enemies
so they come at you you gotta stay
behind pillars so the turrets are not
shooting at you that kind of thing oh
there are 2 Boston in the game one at
the end the level 4 and then the
mainframe boss which is less boss there
are bunch of items only Nyjah you died
that was alright though it was a good
run really reach level two is that a
pretty pretty solid outing well I mean
you know not exactly the the most fergie
and I was easy circumstances to the game
demo well as you play the game you learn
the mechanics and you get better at it
at one point you will beat the game and
then I'm I'm figuring out leaderboard so
people can try to speed run and be
faster at the game because once you get
skilled it really becomes a whole
different game you know you just gotta
take the games you get good at it if you
take it slowly if you just rush into
rooms you're gonna die it's going to be
room for
so you got to take it slow listen so you
can listen to what's going on in the
world like audio cools are very
important and the music's made by those
one yeah he's like great guy very
talented musician and he's insane I
think that's one of the things I really
love about many independent games as
they you know it's there's often a
collaboration between game design and a
musician and the music then becomes such
an influential part of the game and the
aesthetic and the experience of flying
yeah and he's come up with a lot of good
ideas that we're putting in the game
like the player he has like some voices
now like when you get poison it's like
we're it's so cool I hope you get
poisoned soon so you can hear I hope you
get boys it Nigel yeah thanks for coming
up there's some items that you can pick
up you can find a key card they're
locked behind the locked doors okay it
also secret items if you find them
there's a little X on the wall sometimes
some weird stuff in the secret items
just you know you sort of the walls sort
of seem like they would start to look
the same sort of got these color
gradients and you've gone you got a few
environmental things like the these sort
of rocks and he spires knees abutments
so but you know you have to be on the
lookout for these sort of little little
clues yeah you start learning about the
universe when you're playing because you
got for example these that snake oh wow
it gets a lot of people I don't know
where but you learned that they're
always around these bushes just being
bushes so you start looking out for them
then you start feeling comfortable they
start getting you again because you said
stop looking up with them so it's really
cool that's not and so you know you're
talking about dying a lot in this game
talking about making the challenge for
the player there and I feel like one of
the tough parts about roguelike
development is finding that line between
like you know throw your hands up an
agony challenge or one more try one more
try you know I learned a little bit i'm
getting a little bit better that kind of
challenge well that's where early access
has been really cool because people
would be helping like a lot of really
really a lot of feedback i'll just
seeing how people find about the
difficulty so like when we press release
on early access sorry people were having
a hard time with the first few levels
aha and then once they figure that out
the later levels were be easy for the
so i had a like rebalance everything and
all the first two levels that be easier
you got some new ways to jail and it's
hard because by yourself you know you
can't figure that stuff out so steam
users have been really really cool
that's great it's always great when
games in gender that sense of community
and like yeah I need a little help here
is there someone who can help me out and
so the early access community of course
that's on Steam folks can download it
for the pc now and you you've been how
long has it been on there how many
updates have you sort of put out for it
I'm trying to do weekly updates it's
been like a month this week I'm not
gonna do it because I'm over here but
next we come back at work your weekly
update is posting this video you know to
that Jersey page when you get back so be
fixing bugs you know just getting more
continent seeing what people feel about
the game balancing it spins it's been
awesome really I really it's my first
game right and I've really loving making
games and it's so good that's pretty
incredible too I mean your first game so
what's your your sort of you know did
you poke around with like modding map
sir did you go to school for design like
how did you come into this and decide
like all right this is gonna happen i'm
gonna make a game yeah so I've been a
graphic designer interactive designer
for some years now um I have a lot of
free time because I work from home and I
love games and I've just seen what
people are doing it was like I gotta get
in on this so I've no internet you can
just figure everything out with the
internet sitting trot yeah the stuff is
out there you just need to have the time
to dedicate to it yeah so I just I shut
down my facebook you know Slater and
just focus on learning the game it's
been really hard but really rewarding
for sure and I'm making games is so
exciting when you start thinking about
what you're gonna do in the future right
it's just so crazy and um this game I I
just started playing around with an idea
for a game Jim it was 70 FPS because
when I started and I just liked it he
just kept going with it you know because
I was having fun with the game myself
and and I can't believe I'm here then
here you are showing off heavy bullets
here at e3 and it's looking pretty
incredible folks just a reminder we're
going to be taking your questions on all
the games we're playing here on the live
stage show you can send them to us via
twitter using the hashtag gamespot III
or into the game spot chat right there
on the stream you are watching and this
is heavy bullets right now Nigel making
pretty good work of these true
you guys coming at him got snaked at one
point but will forgive you you know
there we go he's learning you go back to
get the item there's some doors are
locked and you got to find a key card
like this one uh-huh so if you open it
you get like in this case bombs but it's
random so it really depends on what are
you doing are there in terms of sort of
the items set how sort of diverse are
you getting about player you know what
the player can use abilities and stuff
very diverse well some stuff is very
useful other stuffs not so much but
since the game is randomized I think
that's kind of cool because you just
find a new item and you gotta like
figure out how it works is one of the
things you for I mean are you talking
about like you could find some bombs or
you could find a hat doesn't it look
Shanti yep you got teleporter proximity
sensor like homing bombs mega bumps you
got weird stuff like high heels and
stuff like that you can find out the
game and I try to make sense of it the
items you can sell the items if you want
you don't have to use them open store
them for later like another plate throw
that kind of thing you know there's a
secret item so it's a gold skull gold oh
that's so that seems to me yeah you know
like you would want to sell it but what
can we look at that screw that Paul
screen again real quick you have it
you've got different levels of your
abilities here yeah sure so like the
reload if you upgrade it you can reload
more than one bullet at the same time at
the start of the game doesn't make that
much of the difference but later on you
really want to upgrade that thing in
this case you can see that the item you
know I it's the secret items i'm a bit
memory serious with those you got to
figure those out in this case it gives
you more money when you kill something
the goals it's kind of a sense it's in
yet but you can also sell it for some
some nights kasia and i'm sure that's
something that the community enjoys
trying to figure out yeah yeah people
have been figuring out stuff for
themselves and it's been really cool i
try to not say anything just I don't
figure it out have fun you know because
it's kind of what I like with games when
I might play them you know yeah learning
about it and of course you gotta balance
it out and that's what I'm learning
before the accident those guys are
really helping me out and it's been
really cool very cool ah we've got a
question coming in via twitter user
wondering is there anything that people
have not figured out yet what is their
stuff out there that people are still
pull
sling about yet some items people are
trying to figure out what they do uh-huh
I don't want to give it away I don't
watch you yeah I want you to gloat a
little bit here we haven't figured out a
nice to have I think my crazier ideas
for items are still I'm still gonna do
them I want to do some stuff with those
one because that guy is insane i want to
get more of his stuff in the game I
think he just completely changed the
game when he got in so so happy to be
working with them very cool uh so heavy
bullets here it's available now on steam
early access for a pc mac and linux for
pc mac and linux f excellent Terry thank
you so much for coming on and showing it
off the game looks really really cool
you folks you get into it now on PC and
hope you have a great show man thanks
very much